[Musique]
la Chambre d'Agriculture est jumelée
depuis maintenant 6 ans ou 7 ans avec la
chambre de le vivre en Ukraine ville
austro-hongroise à l'origine
c'est-à-dire que et aller c'est une
ville qui est à 70 km à peu près de la
frontière polonaise
les gens sont complètement perdus même à
le vivre qui est à 70 km de la frontière
ukrainienne ils ont pris un bombardement
en fait sur une base aérienne qui est à
40 km de ville donc même à le vivre en
tant que tel ils ont entendu les
déflagrations et cetera il y a un état
d'urgence qui a été décrété c'est-à-dire
que les enfants n'ont plus d'écoles et
les salariés ne peuvent plus aller au
travail ce qui pose que d'ailleurs dans
les exploitations des soucis majeurs
puisque en fait vous avez bon nombre
d'exploitation qui ont des animaux et
donc les chefs d'exploitation sont
obligés de faire le tour des salariés
pour leur demander quand même de venir
au travail pour pouvoir nourrir les
animaux
aujourd'hui le premier objectif je pense
qu'il est humain avant tout c'est-à-dire
c'est de mettre les gens à l'abri en
fait de ce qui peut se passer là-bas
personnellement je vais accueillir
probablement des amis Ukrainiens chez
moi donc on est en train de voir pour
les faire sortir du crâne actuellement
et j'ai pris contact hier avec le
président du conseil départemental des
Yvelines pour voir dans quelle mesure on
pouvait accueillir quelques femmes et
enfants de de de du secteur de le vivre
sachant que les hommes souhaitent rester
sur place pour se battre moi mon
homologue qui est président de la
Chambre d'Agriculture de le vivre qui a
62 ans lui souhaite se battre à 62 ans
il souhaite prendre les armes en fait
pour défendre son pays